hi I'm welcome to episode number 45 or
the weekly go go club back from podcast
hi I'm Francis component I'm here with
my colleague mark Mendell hello hi
Frances can you doing today pretty good
pretty excited about the interview we've
again one of my friends Russell Smith
from brain for sqa he's gonna be telling
us about what they do every first great
and how they use bigquery to power older
analytics analytics analytics yeah
analytics yeah basically analytics no
it's actually really cool they have
again cross cloud it's a an app running
on Heroku and they poured a lot of their
analytics over into bigquery it's pretty
cool yeah I think that that is that is
one of the ways people start using
google cloud platform very often it goes
like I'll be query school because yeah
so yeah very good so yeah we're going to
be talking about that and then at the
end we're gonna have a question of the
week that comes actually we have two
questions of the week one is okay so I
want to do something after i receive an
email not personally but if i were mine
i don't know you might maybe I want my
program to react to emails right how do
I do that what is the best way and then
we also have a question about a painting
services would be used to call panting
modules from one of our listeners us too
I'm gonna say ich farts but Foley
Schwartz shorts I don't know I'm gonna
make it German sound ok fart short but
before that we have the cool things of
the week yeah as usual and the first one
is the obvious one which is urban areas
on the four yeah super excited about
criminales 104 there's a bunch of new
things in here just to pick out a couple
of my favorites both of which are in
alpha but I think they're still really
exciting the first is the cube ATM tool
this is really great so if you don't run
on ji ke and you want to create your own
crib in these clusters we now have like
a command line tool that you can like
spin up masternodes and then join us or
nodes to join it and makes it makes it
much easier still in alpha so still
worth you know like kind of playing with
in providing feedback but definitely the
right direction for community is setting
up a cluster before with
very very difficult yep yeah there was
that document that I'm sure most of you
have heard about which was learning to
brunette is the hard way it was when a
Kelsey's Kelsey Hightower's github yeah
which is a very good document bait was
also very good friction lab I'll say be
like this is really hard so yeah the new
version is making all of those things
easier which is very nice yeah and also
they're gonna have scheduled jobs which
makes me very happy so if you want
something to happen on a time-based
interval yeah that's that's enough for
now as well been waiting for that for
ages yeah it is it is actually very
simple but yeah like I just assume it
was always there personally so it is
very nice to see that is finally there
so yeah if you want to run a I was gonna
say a cron job but which is basically
what it is if you want to run a job like
everyday at 8am now you can well looking
at the syntax actually uses contacts
index yeah so it's basically quantized
it's basically cup it's pretty cool um
the other thing for cool thing of the
week I just wanted to make it like a
call at two some people in our community
and some of the stuff they've been
writing oh I'm going to mess this up
Fernando Damian Lopez I wrote a really
nice little concise blog post about just
starting up a compute engine vm from App
Engine nice i think is a very popular
sort of modulus operandi for a lot of
people was a very common pattern i'm
assuming he's using the rest api he's
using the rest api he's got the source
code in Python there how to configure
the right permissions on how to do stuff
and it's just really clean concise and
like yeah if you wanted to do it from
like a cron job for example or something
like that it's pretty cool yeah we'll
have a we have a link to that on the
show notes and there's actually a fourth
cool thing of the week which is a cool
thing of the day which is Google's 18th
anniversary oh yeah yeah I just thought
about that that's cool happy birthday
Google happy birthday there you go so I
think it's time to go talk to her friend
Russell let's do that then so I'm very
happy to welcome Russell's may due to
the podcast hello how are you doing good
how you doing very happy very excited
about all the questions we're gonna be
asking you today especially about the
end about bigquery he just shared a
number of rows with me and I think it's
for amazing so but before we get into
the details of data and stuff like that
well then you tell us a little bit about
who you are and what do you do cool so
yeah I'm Russell CTO and co-founder of
rainforest QA and basically CTO M means
a lot of different things to different
people but for me it's I've run the
technical side of rainforest so I'm
responsible for the direction and
basically that we're successful
technically and so yeah been going about
four or five years now so 2012 late 2011
2012 kind of thing moved over from the
UK with Fred my co-founder the CEO and
what got into YC and started working on
rainforest shortly after that so yeah
that's a brief history of Russ cool well
that sounds really interesting um why do
you tell us a little bit about what
rainforest QA what's like the general
jist what is that was the company do
cool as the rainforest is QA is a
service so we give you a web interface
and api's and command-line tools in
order to do your QA so you can go in and
two tests in plain English so whether
you're a developer or a PM you can write
a basically regression test for your web
app and then you can trigger them either
using the interface or using the API or
put it into your CI build which is one
of the most common ways of doing it so
we enable you to do human powered QA is
super super fast in a normal continuous
integration build so a lot of our
customers are using it to speed up their
release process by doing their QA in
stuff like circle CI or Jenkins which is
pretty cool the other thing is because
as in plain English is enabling other
people on the team to write more
maintainable test than would be with
something like whatever general
automation tools which gen if you guys
have ever used them generally pretty
brittle writing stuff in plain English
whilst at taz's nuances generally leads
to a test that is more reliable once
you've got it nailed down so I could
write like a script where I could be
like you know go get a product that's
green and then put in your shopping cart
and help go through to check out and yep
some would actually go ahead and do that
yeah the classic one would be to like
ask them to sign up and ask them to
check if the email was received or if
they got a text message to a number and
all those kind of extra tool
round email checking third party or
getting phone numbers and stuff is all
handled by us and all automatic and
pretty awesome cool so just to have an
idea how does it actually work like if I
if I do this thing I was like I have my
first question like how does it like my
version and I'm like oh yeah I want to
run some tests so I give you my script
which is like for instance I'll know log
into GC podcast calm and click on
download an episode 45 for Indian great
yeah so okay basically we store all the
stuff for you all your tests for you or
you can store them in plain text in your
repo and then just upload them to us
automatically once you actually hit our
API and say hey rain forest run all
these tests we do a couple of things one
we copy all those tests and version them
so that if you ever change your test in
the future we know which ones we ran
here but then the next thing is we start
farming it out to the workers we've got
online so normally we have a few
thousand workers up to like 5,000
workers online at any one time and we're
talking about this earlier but we
basically give up the work in kind of a
special way so we use elixir project
this is one of our first Alexa
Production apps that connects to a
Chrome extension that the test is
download so we know which testers are
online when and when they want to work
so much like say uber when you want to
do rides as an uber driver you just open
up the up and say hey I want to do right
for our testers they just open up their
browser and then they just click on the
icon for rain forest and it just turns
it on and we know that they won't work
and then we can just type the work to
them and so we can say hey this person's
mollified for the job that you've just
asked for we're going to give that to
you and so we can do that very very
quickly so I guess stepping back a bit
the traditional way of doing this with
the crowd source based system so
something like em Turk or crowd flower
would be you do the cool to rain forests
rainforest then does a cool too crowd
flower say and says hey list a job on
the service and then we list a job there
then the worker goes to the page when
they feel like it refreshes a page sees
like a craigslist
listing of things to do click someone
maybe decides to do it and then like
does it so that process took unknown
three to seven minutes to do maybe
traditionally and then relied on workers
actually refreshing so we ended up
building notification services on top of
that but then we realized the easier way
to do is just to make them install the
chrome extension will have them install
a Chrome extension so this is much more
fluid way so after pressing the button
or using the API or doing it in a build
it's generally a few seconds before we
get the first workers during your work
which is pretty crazy when you realize
how many humans that is yeah there's
that is pretty amazing now we
accidentally did or not dido spit we
take people down all religious so it's
running for functional it was like oh
yeah it doesn't yeah yeah so I mean
that's one of the things we've got a
ship this quarter is something to allow
us to limit the parallel ISM because I
guess unlike say if you're doing testing
traditionally with selenium style stuff
a lot of the crowd crowd cloud-hosted
providers for that rule maybe you'll get
64 parallel other things at once we can
do a couple of thousand things in
parallel so that tends to put a large
amount of load on your system if you're
not used to it nice so for mine
architecture up on a view sure how does
how does rain forest QA distribute all
of these flows like are these
applications that you're testing running
on the customer side and you manage
their yeah generally well in fact a
hundred percent of cases the application
is running the customer runs it and the
main reason why is this well you guys
are developers it's like so many
different ways of running something and
so many different ways of having
dependencies and getting in the right
state it's just totally non trivial to
do right to run somebody else's app so
we let you run that and and generally
people deploy to a staging or QA
environment and then point rainforest at
that works pretty well if you're on her
occur you can actually use this feature
called review apps which is pretty
badass if you do
request it will start and HAP with that
code and then you can point rainforest
at that as well I know you were talking
about doing that for Google right for
your App Engine stuff yeah trying to
implement something like that it is fun
and I don't think it is the heart so
maybe we'll be able to share some ways
yes well you could use an app engine
version manually yeah you get so yeah
what I'm trying to do is not a food that
my yeah yeah you could be fun with me
yeah so so that is about all the web
integration test right like all that is
about the web what about mobile but buff
first yeah actually that's a good point
we launched I guess we've been running
mobile for I don't know maybe five or
six months now for a few customers maybe
10 customers and then last week we
launched a self-serve version of this
that anyone can sign up to today where
you prepay for credits rodham enter into
a contract with us so yeah we're powered
by amazon's device farm i see who is
cringing there you guys didn't do iOS
fast enough on your firebase stuff so we
had to cover them but they're awesome so
they give us real devices like direct
and well I say direct so they give us a
real devices but the way they're
designed was for running automated tests
so because we're powered by humans we
actually need to like give the device to
them as in presented to the tester it
wasn't really set up for that so we had
to build some pretty cool tech to allow
us to basically transport the device
into the person's browser so short
version is we wrote a VNC server and an
ssh server in some reverse tunneling
magic that goes into the app so we can
inject it into your app and then when
your app starts on there we can reverse
tunnel back into it and take control of
the phone which is kind of awesome
because it turns out actually works even
though it sounds totally crazy yeah but
it just means we can run like 100-200
devices at once and give them out to
test as instantly so super low friction
for you as a end user as a customer also
you again writing test in plain English
so like that very low brittleness of
your tests and also super easy to get
started so with all of these testers and
all the tests and devices that you can
be running at the same time I'm
imagining that you are generating a
pretty decent man of data how do you how
do you handle that like that you create
a like do I get a an email saying past
oh yeah well actually kinda so at a high
level yeah you'll get there's a bunch of
ways of notify me but one of the classic
ones is email so you will get an email
that just says past but then it lists
all the tests that is past the
interesting one is when you get failures
like will send you the failure in what
browser or device it failed on and then
if you link click on the link you can go
down into like seeing what the tester
did where whether that's through
screenshots or device looks for iOS
stuff or for web stuff will give you
half format which is I guess you guys
are Google people so it's a format i
think invented here it's chrome exports
from the network debug panel so anyway
we'll give you that same format which
means you can use some of the same tools
to like introspect it and figure out
what's going on but so you can get the
actual logs because we man in the middle
our own machines to be able to track all
the requests that go through all the
requests that the testers do does that
make sense yep yeah that as for where we
store that data it's a bunch of it is in
Postgres some of it now is going into a
Google bigquery and then a bunch of it
is stored on s3 so the staticky stuff
that doesn't change is stored on us
three so you said some of it goes to
bigquery now you were sharing a really
lug number with this earlier is that
really just some of the data yeah that's
just some of the data so um the short
version we are having we use Heroku like
a lot almost all event infrastructures
on Heroku apart from the machines that
provide virtual machines to testers
they're in a different place and but
heroic has this like super little-known
feature um cool log drains and log
drains let you pipe log output from your
app
all the like processes of the app to
anywhere you want so like traditionally
that only supported syslog but they like
added an undocumented door I think at
the time undocumented feature where you
could do http-based transport so I spoke
with you guys like maybe a year or that
year or two ago year ago maybe yeah and
figured out hey i'm just going to write
a go program that uses the streaming API
for bigquery and just takes in all the
logs from our entire infrastructure and
puts them into Vickery so now the the
cool thing is we're having a bunch of
problems with a logging provider who I'm
guessing I should probably not name
because I don't want any palate politics
here but we were looking for a good log
provider one that was fast and
searchable and didn't have bad retention
and didn't cost us an absolute fortune a
year and then realize like actually
there aren't any we by the way we since
found log DNA home which I highly
recommend those guys they're like cheap
they do like a good job they're not
super losa bells and whistles but that's
that's the trade off with them they just
do what you need which is such but
anyway we still use a bit query for this
so go program streaming API takes in all
the logs from our whole infrastructure
and just puts it straight into table and
it all just also does some extra nice
stuff for parsing out the different
fields and putting them to the right
clothes but yeah we've got about 25
billion log lines in in bigquery now so
it's kind of cool that that's really
cool do you know like how much do you
tend to ingest can you share that with
this am I good processes play grade uh
it's normally a floor of like a thousand
a thousand rows a second kind of thing
and then it goes up depending on traffic
so that's normally our baseline for ring
first maybe a bit lower the weekend but
during the week it's about that so so
it's not super high log look wise i
guess it's bikes though yeah i mean
1,000 requests per second is pretty
decent time to be honest oh so tripoli
the the program a I've been meaning to
open source forever so I should probably
actually do it
that'd be it runs on Heroku so it's like
self it's kind of weird Heroku logs
going to Heroku hey then going to you
guys so yeah super cool and that's cool
so once the data is in bigquery what are
you actually doing with it there yeah
good question as so we have a bunch of
standard queries that we run to find
some issues so we either run them
directly in your dashboard or we use
something could read ash which I think
you actually recommend it to me I like a
while ago but read ash for those of you
that don't know is kind of open source
dashboarding system but it lets you run
queries on schedules and it connects to
like postgres [ __ ] my sequel but also
bigquery and redshift and like etc etc
etc so it's super cool for that so we
use that so we have a bunch of queries
that run regularly to find certain
things that we're looking forward to
stats and super awesome because it's
cheap to run on you guys and it's all so
fast so having dared a man of of rose
and bigquery I'm wondering how do you
manage the you actually have a bunch of
different tables it's just a one
humongous table with silly as a row so
this is the the noob mistake which I I
need to fix which I was reading the docs
about recently but when I first started
I didn't realize that we should do named
date version tables and turns out like
at least in the past that was impossible
to fix without just making a new set of
tables which I didn't really want to do
here so i think i read the docs
correctly saying that i can actually do
that now without taking off line which
looks kind of cool so anyway I haven't
got around to it because the cost is
actually low enough that I don't care
yet that is nice even though like I'm
kind of attracted by the fact that if
the date is still for a month or
something it's like half the cost is
that correct there's some discount if
it's the data doesn't get added to after
a period of time anyway most of I should
check that out I my chair not sure no I
was digging around the the bigquery docs
so I'm pretty sure that's correct but
google it yourself oh yes so if at a
is not edited for 90 consecutive days
the price of storage that table
automatically drops by 50% 20 point 0.01
per gigabyte which is totally insane one
cent per game buddy oh wow it's insane
and it's also awesome that is for ya so
we will end big query from him that is
it that's why we do because we're not
very good at this I need to switch to
partition tables so that we can take
advantage yeah that way no we have one
table with nearly 25 billion Rosen so
yeah and it's working yeah it which is
kind of cool out of curiosity like what
how long does it take to execute the
mosque complex square you have and so
normally we get we don't really run
queries over the full dataset unless
there's some security thing that is
probably just and there's this awesome
thing in Vickery where you can scope by
not by data in the table but by when
that data was inserted okay so almost
all our queries it I camera but it's
cooled anyway almost all our queries are
done by that so they're normally if
you're depending what you're doing then
only either a day or weeks worth of
stuff okay which i think is actually the
max for that but only on rare
circumstances do we query all of the
data ever but is so it's normally if we
have something that somebody's like oh
this thing happened like two months ago
can you help us I'm like yeah maybe we
can turns out a bit so yeah we don't
normally query the whole dataset but so
things are pretty quick like normally
sub a minute I mean we queried earlier
to find out how many roads were in the
table today and that was the longest
square I've ever seen which was just
over a minute and that's because it
counted every single thing ever which is
kind of still really cool 68 68 seconds
68 seconds to count 20 billion 25 being
a reticle that is that bad I can live
with that you're talking about your
visualizations and you were saying
you're using it to like find certain
issues and things can you talk a little
bit more like what sort of issues that
are you looking for or how are you using
it in the visualizations yeah so I know
we're looking at trends so we're also
using another another awesome products
to do this which seems to actually be
the better way of doing it
your vision we're looking at trends in
like memory usage or like load can we
spot any trends that are outliers and
then dig into why this happened so we
actually using a service called honey
honeycomb dot io which also i think is
in beta but can super recommend those
guys short version we're trying to find
like hey this bunch of requests was slow
like why why was that and then for
instance we are investigating the other
day and found one of our dinos which I
guess grow coupons for like a machine
running a process was using way more
swap than all the other machines for no
apparent reason so like digging into
that well even finding that was only
possible using Vickery and honeycomb so
most you data really is about like
machine analytics and yeah yeah so yeah
we haven't moved to there's another
thing that we're working on which is to
use to move some of our data a lot of
our most important tables from postgres
into bickering and the main reason we
want to do that is for doing like
analytics so like finding out turns out
we have too much data to you to be able
to query the entire thing at a
reasonable speed on postgres so we've
got i'm coming up to 3 or 400 gigs of
data which actually doesn't seem like
that much but turns out is enough it's
expensive to run at a fast speed when
we're doing stupid queries but padding
so anyway short version which we're
working on a way of exporting that data
direct into bigquery which will mean
that we can do the more insane queries
faster which is gonna be cool nobody
will open source that as well yeah you
should should open source the first one
as well yeah and write a block both you
said good point so now that you've been
using bigquery for a while and I'm as
you were saying you had some noob
mistakes like having just one huge table
forever
thank ya do you have any other piece of
advice for people that are starting to
migrate there they have like a huge
database relational and they're like oh
should i use sure they move to bigquery
sure um yeah basically like the biggest
limitation when I started doing it was i
well I guess I did read the docs but I
just didn't bother doing a bunch of
stuff as I wanted to get started but
like the biggest thing I would say now
is make sure you read the docs properly
and probably go with the standard sequel
stuff which seems to be the new version
I'm still on the older version standard
sequel seems super awesome because he
removes one of the major limitations of
bakery which is updating stuff which
like now you can treat it almost like a
proper yeah almost like a proper
database yeah that is actually i don't i
don't mean that meanly by the way like
no no like it's not like just depend on
me now you can actually update things
for quite a long time yeah bigquery was
only a pen only you you could be I mean
totally makes sense if you're talking
about something to analyze large to
totally make sense modifier lives for us
but yeah horrible use case for the
analytics stuff for us yes like need to
just drop it every time we want to
update again which I guess is also
possible just yeah I would say
definitely look at the streaming API is
pretty awesome um it also means stuffs
really fast um there's a really good go
library for it that I found which I will
get put in the podcast knows yeah we'll
put it on the show notes yeah and then I
guess the only other thing would you
want to do to wrap up like the only
other thing I was going to say was I'm
in reinvent I'm speaking at reinvent
about mtech so if anyone was to come say
hi to that i'll also be at the CTO
summit in november so if anyone wants to
say hi there do it cool yeah go find him
and ask him about bigquery yeah turku
sourcing stuff so cool well thank you so
much for taking the time today to talk
with us that's a very interesting
interview I will have a bunch of links
to all the different projects that
you've mentioned and hopefully we also
have links to the open source versions
of your pro here
Severson okay um I just hide the VPN so
i should actually have some time to do
this kind of stuff man also awesome well
thank you cool thanks guys thanks it was
a pleasure and a joy to have Russell
Smith on with us today I definitely
appreciate hearing her by people
building interesting things especially I
think across cloud I think that's really
interesting to see how people are doing
that sort of stuff it was really good in
the amount of data he's processing
station station amount it is yeah when
he was walking away we had a quick chat
and one of the things that I was saying
is like oh so like you have like 25
billion rows are they like very short
rows like oh no like they have like like
tens or more feels like oh wow okay and
some of the fields have Jason insides
there's like decent amount of data to
that Wow yeah very cool so yeah looking
forward to all the open sourcing of
those tools and very excited about it
especially because the reigning oh yes
yeah very good is make you very happy
alright cool so let's get into our
questions apparently questions of the
week yeah yeah you raise the first one
which i think is an interesting one and
got me very excited which is how to
react to email from google cloud to say
I I don't know this is this is always a
fun one I'm getting get sent an email
but some third-party make for you for
example and I want to be able to
automatically do something about it once
i receive it what how can i find out
when like that email comes to me so I
composites data and do stuff like that
so so these actually comes from a
customer that asked me this question and
it was pretty fun because they were like
you know what they need to do something
very complex on compute engine right and
that very complex job needs to be done
every single time that someone could
update a database that it was publicly
available built by NASA actually okay
and the impressive thing is that the way
they could notify people about there's
any there's new data in the database is
by sending emails of course so yeah so
you had someone that was receiving that
email that then good go and run a script
that good start everything right and I
was like I'm pretty sure there's better
way to do this yep and there's many ways
of doing it one of them could be run
your own web server I wept
on your own mail server let's don't do
that that doesn't sound like that is
that yet that is definitely fun then
another thing you could do is basically
use imap to connect from your script
that runs regularly like for instance
using chrome and every our checks if
there's name email that name email to
start doing stuff but then the problem
is that how often do you Ted do you
check your basically polling yeah so
you're pulling all the time so it's kind
of not perfect and there's actually very
very very easy solution which is just
using App Engine so so App Engine can
receive email yeah so you actually get
the same way you get a URL to host your
web server which is like your app ID
appspot com you also get an email which
is whatever you want at your app ID
appspot mail com so if you send an email
to that address what will happen is that
the email will be sent as a as a PO as a
post HTTP request to your application so
now if your instance is not running like
your application is not running because
you don't have any traffic which
probably know more if you're only
receiving mail once a day what will
happen is that when you receive that
request your new instance will start and
you will treat that and then you do
whatever you want and one of the things
that you can as we said at the beginning
of the podcast well as that you can
start a new computer and generations and
then from there you do whatever you need
um I'm just actually genuinely going
away that App Engine can just give me
mail like it didn't realize it could do
this and it's so cool the best buy that
has been there for like ever it is
really namu it is a like very simple and
if you don't know what it's there yeah
uh it is it is good my mind is it is
truly boy yep it is it is a pretty fun
thing to do and talk about App Engine we
also have a second question of the week
coming from our French through smart or
chart tell us how you pronounce it so is
about a bunch in services with which
four people have been using a pension
for a while you might have known
as App Engine modules and he's asking
okay so when should I use a pension
versus gke and it is a scale issue and
approach issue implementation issue and
then the second question which is more
related to App Engine services is should
I have a bunch of services should i have
a bunch of projects and one service for
project and the answer to the second
part of the question is well have as
many services you need micro services
are awesome and when you say services we
talk about modules modules yeah so you
can have basically a different app it's
basically a different app engine
application but they share the same
resources right so if you want to make
them communicate through like rest rest
you can but also if you can use task
task queues and all of these things and
it's very easy to communicate because
their own same project when to use more
than one project normally I could
reserve that two different environments
so you have like prod QA stuff like that
then those are good because that way
you're not sharing the data store which
is probably a good idea if you yeah like
you should not give access to the proud
data just to the test right so it is it
is a good place to separate but you you
should have all your production services
in one single project much easier to
handle and then about the question when
to use App Engine versus gke maybe you
can give us a little bit of background
on that yeah so I this is an interesting
question I'll I'll hakan back for more
detailed response to our episode number
to compute as a continuum yeah where we
go in too much nuance detail about it
but I feel like it's really more a
question of how much flexibility and
control do you want App Engine standard
nap inch and flexible give you slightly
different versions of that whereas you
know App Engine standard platform as a
service we dictate you know a lot of
things about how you do stuff but that
gives you great scale Jeff really
powerful flex we give you a few more
configuration options a few more like
bits and pieces so you can run pretty
much anything you want it but now you
can't scale 20 we don't spit up quite as
fast so there's the tray off but if you
want still the sort of capability such
that things stay up if they fall over
they come back
you still want to be able to deploy with
the rolling update things like that gk
use a great place for that but you now
have even more tweaks and knobs that you
can pull right yeah you'll have a
cluster of machines in that case you'll
pay for that cluster machines you can
auto scale it to a degree but then you
can do things like resource management
or have jobs or now scheduled jobs as
well what's that once that comes out of
alpha but you have way more control and
you can start to say you know maybe I
want to have stuff with a whole bunch of
memory in it which is way more than I'd
be able to get on App Engine or
something like that persistent volume
mounts about their state that I want to
be able to put in places things that you
can't necessarily do is easy on App
Engine so it's probably really down to
like what sort of application you're
building and then what sort of
capabilities you really want to be able
to have at hand yeah my rule of thumb is
if it can run an app engine it will run
on App Engine because that way I can
forget about like all the DevOps and I
just deployed it and I know it will be
running there forever yep and that makes
me happy but if it's something that I'm
gonna need to be like oh no like I have
all of these services and there's
dependencies across them and I want them
to be able to scale them independently
and I did them independently and all
that stuff then GK is probably the best
place yeah it's in pretty variable cool
uh well why don't you tell us a little
bit about what you're gonna be doing
next week's so I've got a lot of trouble
I say that with some sadness knocked
over but I'm doing some fun event so
that's pretty cool so i will be at siege
in atlanta on the 8th of october that's
gonna be fun gaming conference after
that i will be a connectech on the 20th
i'll be back at lander again on the 20th
that's a general web dev conference and
then i'll be a gamer con another game
conference on the twenty-seventh so i
have a fair bit a travel in october nice
and yourself where are you doing so next
week I will be in New York and I'm going
to be running a workshop and you're all
invited it's going to be on Wednesday
fifth yeah where's the fifth October
fifth so next wednesday and yeah it's
about how to be a highly scalable web
applications with go on App Engine cool
and it's gonna be hosted by women who go
in New York but everyone is welcome so
we'll have a link on the show notes to
to that and then I'm also very excited
about something else which is not
traveling but kinda I'm gonna be doing a
remote I've remote meet up so yeah and
that will be on monday after that so in
october temp and it's gonna be kind of
the same so it's a mini workshop and
it's how to build a web application it
says with France desk it will be with go
actually but but yeah basically it's
gonna be online and you can ask all the
questions that you want so if you will
be in New York next week you're all
invited to come to that workshop but if
not the Monday after that there will be
something online and you can be there
whatever in the world you are and also
it will be recorded so you can watch it
later if you want you that's cool I
should make mention that if you are at
any of the events that we're going to be
at we do have new gcp podcast speakers
we have stickers and they're awesome
yeah and they're also so if you happen
to be where we are and you want to come
up and say hi and get a sticker please
do yeah yeah and we also have t-shirts
we don't wait on travel wrong with
t-shirts all the time now sometimes I do
yeah but what's the gap stickers away
ESO carry come find us and got stickers
absolutely all right well thank you very
much for an Cesc for joining me yet
again thank you Mark uh and talk to you
next week see you next week
you